I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense you know I always joke with
Laird after I mean literally November
we'll be together for 24 years and I'm
like you know you're here always like I
always want him to feel like oh yeah I
could go anytime I want because then he
doesn't feel the there's no pressure
about being there it's understanding
like I'm exactly where I want to be when
you look at it like that if you go
there's no pressure to be here you're
free right and that person keeps coming
home to you that means more than if they
feel trapped you know so that's if you
can just like let go of the control and
the wanting of something for yourself so
much yeah and love the person totally no
matter what it is and they are free to
go like they can go do what they want
and go period if they want and they know
that and if they keep coming back that
actually speaks significant volumes
compared to the other where it's like
right oh yeah all handbrakes got me at
home can't go anything oh I kind of got
a lie to her and say I was yeah I mean
that's that's shitty little there's much
fulfillment in the freedom for yourself
if you can just get there one you know
I'm coming home to learn he's not coming
home to me just be clear about that I'm
still coming home to him why do you say
it like that I'm joking I'm kidding he's
not coming home it's all sure no I'm
joking but I think the other side of
that too is you know I've had once in a
while if we get a little bit husband e
wifey kind of thing we'll be in bed and
I'll say I'm pretty matter-of-fact like
I'm actually not emotional and lucky for
Laird I'm not I really take my time to
respond to things especially the heat if
they get heated you know I don't just go
out you know I mean you have to really
get me good for me just to go straight
is he more ballistic oh yeah well he's
not ballistic he's he's interesting he's
purely emotional and sort of intuitive
but the heavier situation gets the more
calm Laird gets right so he but he's all
emotional you know and so um it's the
part foot wave he's looking at he goes
oh yeah he slows it way down right and
we're being bed and I'll say you know
you really did treat me like a wife
today okay
did I and I'm like yeah and he goes okay
sorry sorry because it's like hey listen
I want to do everything for you yeah you
know I want to I want to make your life
better I want to serve you the best that
I can like I do our children and like
our friends yeah but do you not treat me
like your wife you can treat me like
your girlfriend and we'll be fine that's
actually great yeah I don't say more
than that I just like that you know you
you're kind of treating me like your
wife today and he'll say do you know so
well that's a bad thing then well it's
just it's filling thank you I granted
it's a little like it's a norm like you
do this I like little passive that's not
so Sparky and be your check joyful it's
like it's like just it is whatever yeah
oh my god so and I don't know I'm just a
lawyer that's all right I'm that maybe I
should just stay his girlfriend forever
listen it's all idols and baloney anyway
I've seen people who are in
relationships they're more married than
married the institutions of the world
are really interesting to me and and
marriage is one of them because you know
look if you got married and you you know
back in the old days before they had
tattoo removal it would be like a tattoo
like it's just there forever yeah but
you know nowadays especially and even in
the past you could still separate you
can still divorce but it's so much more
normal now it kind of makes you question
the institution
[Music]